mitte september wird die raumsonde
cassini in die atmosphäre des saturns
stürzen und dort verglühen ein
spektakuläres ende mit explosionen doch
bis dahin steht noch so einiges auf der
to do liste von cassini alle wichtigen
infos zur casinis finale und wie ihr
absturz genau ablaufen wird jetzt in
klicks um science-fiction herzlich
willkommen
die schwierigsten herausforderungen gab
es bei der cassini mission noch vor
ihrem start bei 197 mehrmals stand das
projekt ja auf der kippe mit insgesamt
mehr als drei milliarden dollar war es
den usa zu teuer und wurde immer wieder
in frage gestellt aber dann am 15
oktober 1997 startete eine der
ehrgeizigsten missionen der menschheit
damals wog die sonde 5700 kilogramm also
fast sechs tonnen mehr als die hälfte
des gewichts machte der treibstoff aus
und drei tonnen molekül hydrazin und
als oxidationsmittel also damit brennt
die stickstoffdioxid nach rund 1,5
milliarden kilometern und sechs jahren
war sie dann endlich in der umlaufbahn
des saturns angekommen der länder
ruhiges wurde auf dem unwirtlichen mond
titan abgesetzt und konnte sogar 72
stunden lang daten senden zum ersten mal
konnten so bilder von titan gemacht
werden
die dichte atmosphäre verhinderte dass
bis dahin der größte erfolg der
mission bisher auf dem saturnmond
enceladus wurden bedingungen für
mögliches außerirdisches leben
entdeckt dafür von führte die
saturnsonde ein absolut spektakuläres
manöver
sie verbrachte ein kunststück für das
sie eigentlich gar nicht vorgesehen war
2005 entdeckte die sonne ja aktive
geysire auf dem saturnmond enceladus
danach wurde die komplette mission
verändert die instrumente an bord
wurden umprogrammiert und cassini flug
sieben mal durch die fontänen am
südpol von enceladus cassini lieferte
noch mehr ab beispielsweise qualitativ
hochwertige bilder von venus jupiter und
natürlich den saturnmond und ringen
sowie viele spannende daten zu deren
zusammensetzung wenn man es genau nimmt
konnten überhaupt 7 saturnmonde erst
durch die von cassini gelieferten daten
entdeckt werden seit april dieses jahres
hatte die nasa-sonde mit den
tauchgängen durch die saturnringe
begonnen dabei sind wir wirklich
faszinierende aufnahmen gelungen wir
haben es geschafft hatte die nasa am 27
april getwittert und das war wirklich
ein sensationeller erfolg die raumsonde
war in völlig unerforscht terror gelang
catania hatte sich der wolkendecke von
saturn auf bis zu 3000 kilometer gen er
so nah wie nie zuvor
ihre krassen manöver in den bis dahin
unerforscht gebieten zwischen saturn und
seinen inneren ringen werden wohl so
schnell nicht vergessen werden
doch jetzt geht die reise zu ende der
treibstoff von cassini also sie drei
tonnen sind aufgebraucht und die nasa
hat beschlossen diese mission zu beenden
und zwar gezielt damit die sonde nicht
unkontrolliert crash denn das risiko bei
dem crash saturnmonde mit mikroben von
der erde zu kontaminieren also zur
verunreinigung dieses risiko ist im
forschungsteam viel zu hoch denn wir
haben ja hier schon öfter darüber
berichtet dort könnte eben eventuell
leben existieren dass es noch zu
erforschen gilt und das ging nicht mehr
so gut wenn ein mond kontaminiert wurde
und der erste schritt zum kontrollierten
absturz von cassini ist bereits getan
ihre flugbahn ist so abgelenkt dass sie
in den saturn führt wo sie dann mitte
september auch für immer goodbye sagen
wird aber wir sagen gibt es noch so
einiges für sie zu tun daten sollen
gesammelt und aufnahmen gemacht werden
zum beispiel weitere bilder vom saturn
system mit seinen monden titan und
enceladus und auch von der leuchtenden
saturn aura die nasa teams erhoffen sich
zudem noch weitere details zu den
temperaturen und den wirbeln an den
polen des planeten am 9 september wird
cassini dann laut nasa informationen
knapp 1700 kilometer über den höchsten
wolken des saturns das letzte mal
zwischen ihm und seinen ringen hindurch
tauchen 48 stunden später wird sie dann
den titan passieren bevor sie
schließlich laut plan am 14 september
die finale datenübertragung zur erde
startet sie endet dann einen tag später
spektakulär für den 15 september ist
das ende geplant
um punkt 1353 mitteleuropäischer
sommerzeit beginnt ihr eintritt in die
atmosphäre
1500 zehn kilometer hoch über den
wolken würze den kontakt zur erde
verlieren auseinanderbrechen und
verglühen wie ein meteor doch cassini
soll noch bis zu ihrer letzten sekunde
senden würde der plan der nasa bei
ihrem absturz sollen letzte
aufschlussreiche daten über radiowellen
an die erde gesendet werden und im
besten fall spannende details zur
saturnatmosphäre liefern nach
spätestens zwei minuten wird der
kontakt wohl aber abbrechen mehr als 3,2
milliarden dollar hat die mission der
nasa esa die italienische
raumfahrtagentur asi und weiteren
beteiligten auch aus deutschland dann
gekostet mitte september
die dann nicht nur für cassini alles zu
ende auch für tausende mitarbeiter aus
mehr als 17 ländern endet ein wichtiges
kapitel auch wenn es noch zahlreiche
daten von cassini gibt die ausgewertet
werden wollen aber darüber werden wir
hier dann natürlich berichten wenn ihr
kein video dazu und auch zu allen
anderen themen verpassen wollt dann
würden wir hier ein abo aufs auge und
vergessen nicht den auf die glocke hier
geht es weiter mit sensations- von staub
aus dem interstellaren raum auch eine
cassini entdeckung sehr sehr spannend
nicht verpassen und draufklicken würde
ich mal sagen und ansonsten bis dann
bleibt dran